Please welcome Jenny McCarthy.
(audience clapping)
Hi.
Hi Drew.
Ooh,
your backdrop looks like a hot date
about to take place.
I know everyone's like, "What's going on with that room?"
I'm like, "Well, I wish it was, for more of a sexy reason,
but it's just my podcast forum."
Okay, I wanted to jump right in
because my number one question for you
is being so good at "The Masked Singer".
Do you have a methodology for questions you'll ask
or does it change based on what you hear?
Do you have a system?
Cause you're so good.
I do have a little bit of one, which is I will.
if I don't feel like I'm getting the story out of
the guest or the celebrity,
Uh huh.
I'll share my own personal experiences first
to show them that I'm vulnerable,
that I have the same boo-boos and then it opens them up
to maybe sharing a little bit more than like,
"If she's a hot mess and sharing that,
maybe I'll share that I'm a hot mess."
I really love that.
That's a way in for you and something I really aspire to
and relate to as well.
Okay, you've also hosted a dating show.
We just did this dating segment.
Do people ask you to set them up?
Do they ask dating advice or like,
things they should look out for?
Do they look to you as someone
who has seen it and kind of has tells?
They have, especially like my own inner circle.
Cause they saw me go through
some pretty disastrous dating periods in my life,
and my therapist and I'm gonna tell this,
anyone pay attention right now if you're dating,
because this is great advice.
My therapist said,
"Jenny, you had this amazing ability
to bleach red flags, white.
You don't even realize but you're
justifying their bad behavior.
What I want you to do is I want you to go
on like 30 blind dates,
'cause I want you to practice noticing red flags
and we're gonna watch how you bleach them white."
So I went on a few dates and the very first,
in the first 20 minutes this guy says to me,
"You know I really hate kids."
Now as a mother, you know I should have been check please
and out the door instead,
here is my bleaching horrific thing that I used to do.
My brain did this, "Well he hasn't met my son."
Mm hm.
A lot of us women think they just haven't gotten
to know me, my world.
That's the other thi-
And most guys, by the way, Drew, I don't know
if you noticed this, but most guys usually
on the first dates, they tell you who they are.
Yes, totally.
They don't have the,
none of us have our representatives out yet, you know?
'Cause for two years we have that representative
like, "Yeah, I love sushi" or "I love football."
Two years later, you're like, "I hate sushi.
I hate football."
You know?
So in that first date you got to pay attention
'cause they're really offering who their authentic self is,
in that moment.
I totally agree.
And I think we, women have sort of
we rewrite it as the information is coming out
or when girlfriends have been like, I mean, he just like
doesn't wanna keep going on.
I'm like, "Good, do you wanna stretch this out any longer?"
That's right.
No, they're doing you a favor.
Buh-bye, this is a good thing.
They're doing you a solid.
It made me may not be what you want right now,
but in the end I thank this person
and applaud them for just like cutting it.
Exactly.
Now,
I was reading this quote that you were saying
about your wonderful man, Donnie Wahlberg about just
you had a hard time explaining, putting into words
the feeling that you guys have with each other
because it's so good, it's so positive,
words almost don't cut it.
They don't, they really don't.
Honestly it paid to wait.
I'll tell you that, no more settling.
I did my therapy.
I paid my dues and then I found my Prince charming
and you know, even Prince charming
and the fairytale doesn't come without work.
Yap.
And one of the things I loved him so much,
like as soon as I met him, I was like,
"How do I not mess this up?"
Like, I'm gonna ask him
before we even have our first fight.
If we can go to therapy together, he might think I'm crazy
but I wanna be able to figure out some tool belts
or tools and discover like how we both fight,
Do both of us shut down.
If we're mad at each other or just one need to communicate.
And by sitting down with a therapist and us figuring out,
"Oh, that's what you do when you fight.
This is what I do."
And then the therapist gave us tools to say,
"Okay, when this happens, this is what you do."
And I'm telling you, it was one of the greatest ideas ever
to go to therapy before there's a problem
to figure out how to have those conversations
with each other.
It was priceless, been priceless.
I love that advice.
You just have a wonderful relationship and you,
the humor and the care and the love
and the way you guys work at it.
And I loved reading about your love and your life and just
you know, I've always celebrated you along the years.
Like, hey, we were both like Playboy girls
at one point in our lives.
Hello, good job, by the way.
Totally.
And I'm just so happy like, that you're killing it
on this giant epic show that I heard your agent was like
maybe skeptical about doing,
and then you watch the Korean version
and we're like, "No, no, no, no,
this is gonna be a hit and it's huge."
That's exactly right.
Yeah, my team around me was a little bit suspicious.
They were like, "Ah", 'cause you know, you get offers and,
90% of them are kind of crazy
They're just being careful.
and weird.
And so this one though, when I saw the Korean version
I said, "No, this checks all the boxes.
This is a game show.
It's got celebrities, it's got singing,
it's got weird costumes.
I'm a little weird.
I think it's perfect."
Well, it was a testament to your gut instinct
and whatever's leading you
because you have serious longevity.
Oh, before we go to commercial
do you have a stain challenge for me?
I sure do what I really pray you can help me, honestly.
I really do need the help.
How can I help?
Okay, so there is a blue dress that I wore to the Emmys,
I think I was hosting it for Fox
and I got body makeup on it.
So if you can figure out how to get that one off,
then the rest of my dresses will be saved.
Okay, literally I really want to attack this
and I just have to say the worst thing
you could start with, is makeup remover.
I don't know why, but it makes it worse and you would think,
"Oh, makeup remover will help."
It's the worst approach to taking off makeup on fabric.
So will you please allow me to attack this stain for you?
And then we can follow up.
I would love nothing more in the whole world than that.
I'm so hot and bothered right now.
Stains really turn me on.
They do, they're my thing.
Look, it's who I am.
I love you for that.
Jenny McCarthy, thank you so much for coming on this show.
Thanks Drew.
"The Masked Singer" airs Wednesday nights on Fox.
I have had so much fun with you, thank you so much.
Me too!
I'd love to come back and thank you so much.
(upbeat music)